through the circuit, evaluating
the gates appropriately, then we see that the final value
on this wire here is a one.
So the entire circuit describes
a sequence of operations that are composed as the figure suggests, and we end up with a function
from two bits to one bit
in this particular case. But in general, there could be any number
of input and output bits.
This particular circuit happens to compute the exclusive OR of the two input bits, so the output is a one
if and only if exactly
one of the two input bits is set to a one and the other one is set to a zero, but that's not really
important, it's just an example.
It's a basic fact about Boolean circuits that any function from any number of bits to any number of bits can be computed
by some Boolean circuit, although sometimes you might
need a very large circuit to compute the function
that you're interested in.
There are other styles that
are used to describe circuits.
For example, this figure
represents exactly the same circuit as we had before, using a style that's perhaps more typical
in electrical engineering, where there are conventions for the shapes that represent different gates.
We aren't going to use
this particular style, but we will introduce
some symbols of our own for different quantum gates, such as Hadamard gates,
Controlled NOT gates,
Toffoli gates, and so on.
Just as an aside, here we can see the origin
of the term circuit.
In the context of electrical engineering, it's very natural to
think about electricity cycling through a circuit.
But in this series we're not
talking about electricity moving through circuits, we're talking about information
moving through circuits.
And once again for us, they will always be acyclic, where the information
moves from left to right.
Here's a different example of
a different type of circuit called an arithmetic circuit.
This time the wires store numbers and the gates represent
arithmetic operations such as addition and multiplication.
Here you can see an example
of an arithmetic circuit.
It's not important for the sake
of this lesson what it does, it's just an example that's
meant to convey the idea that there are different
notions of circuits.
We can also think about
circuits involving randomness, for instance, where the gates represent
probabilistic operations, and if you felt like it,
you could probably sit around all day dreaming up new models of computation based on the notion of circuits.
In the quantum circuit model,
the wires represent Qubits, and the gates represent both unitary operations and measurements.
Here's a very simple example
of a quantum circuit.
There's just one Qubit in this circuit, which is represented
by the horizontal line, and the gates, which are
indicated by squares,
represent unitary operations that are performed on this Qubit.
So there are no measurements
in this particular example.
If we want to give the
Qubit a name such as X, we can indicate that in the diagram by putting an X right
here, that's optional.
Just like we had for the Boolean circuit from a few moments ago, we can think about this circuit
as representing a sequence of operations where time
goes from left to right.
So we start out with X,
we apply the first gate, which is a Hadamard gate
followed by an S gate,
then another Hadamard
gate, and finally a T gate.
We saw these operations
toward the end of lesson one, and here you can see
their matrix descriptions.
So when we perform these
four operations in order, which means first H, then
S, then H again, and then T,
the combined operation is given
by this product right here, keeping in mind that the order
essentially gets reversed
as we talked about in lesson one. If we perform the matrix multiplication, we get this matrix right here,
and so the action of the
circuit on the Qubit X is described by this unitary matrix.
Sometimes we'd like to indicate explicitly in a quantum circuit diagram
what input we're feeding in, and we can do that as you see right here.
In this case, we're inputting
Ket 0 into the circuit.
That's pretty common. We often take Ket 0 to
be the initialized state of a Qubit, but that's not necessary.
We could also consider
applying the circuit to a different state.
If we choose to, we can also
indicate the output state that we get like this.
Here's another example where
this time we have two Qubits named X and Y as you
can see in the diagram.
Here we have a Hadamard gate, which is being applied to the Qubit Y, followed by the gate that's indicated by
this symbol right here,
which is a Controlled NOT gate. We talked about the
Controlled NOT operation in the previous lesson,
and here in this diagram we
can see that the control Qubit is Y, which is indicated by
the small filled in circle,
and the target Qubit is X, which is indicated by the large circle with what looks like a plus sign in it.
It kind of looks like the
symbol for the exclusive OR so it makes sense.